i'm anna belle and I'm from Sydney
Australia I'm studying in Germany and
today I'm going to be showing you around
Matlack we're currently on a riverboat
on the site and it is beautiful but a
little bit windy
it feels very fancy a little too fancy
for me maybe but it actually reminds me
a lot of home when I was a little girl
my job before dinner party was always to
set the table so whilst the decor is a
lot nicer it does have a sense of
familiarity around it great and this
guy's
I think when people think of Australia I
think they think of kangaroo this is a
cockatoo I don't think many people think
of that when they think of Australia but
this is definitely the image that we've
put out into the world kangaroos we have
kangaroos it's very much medieval and it
makes me feel like I've stepped back in
time it's pretty easy to get to it's not
too strenuous so that's a bonus and the
view and you get here it's breathtaking
it's the best view I've seen in silent
and I don't think I'm alone in that
opinion
thanks for joining us today met lack I
hope you got to see if you decide we've
had a really good time filming here so
goodbye